ja ich grüße euch ich bin der matthias
willkommen zum weltlehrertag ich bin vom
amt für rüstung und wertigen
bundesheeres binder qualitätsmanager und
verantwortlich wie die biologische
sicherheit in unserem biolabor was ist
unser auftrag
die untersuchung sämtliche bio gefahren
zum schutz unserer soldatinnen und
soldaten aber auch an alle angehörigen
des bmf aus das kann sein
von einer einfachen schimmel kultur bis
verunreinigungen von wasser bakterieller
natur bis hin zu biologischen
kampfstoffen zur aktuellen lage da kommt
19 pandemie sind wir ebenfalls jetzt ein
einsatz labor
wir haben mehrere teams im in und
ausland unterwegs die antikörper tests
durchführen und auch abstrich proben
nehmen für die spätere analyse hier bei
uns im labor
somit wollen wir sicherstellen dass
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten oder
auch andere mitglieder des bfv im in und
ausland dienst sind überprüft werden und
in der hinsicht auch eine vorsorge haben